yeah there is there's places where you
can walk in and they got jack off stalls
with [ __ ] everything hey bud uh
what's going on with your people and
masturbating
[Music]
serious question okay okay do you ever
have this like [ __ ] I have to bust a
nut I have to jack off why would you
like why would you say I would like to
sub Joe [ __ ] dude that was me like five
minutes ago now you're making me
thinking back oh [ __ ] okay now go ahead
yeah we've all been there I think
everybody has a button okay dude do
ladies at the bus nuts for sure nuts is
a strong word for that one I'm speaking
on behalf all late but I'm saying do you
guys have to release that energy yeah is
it like so out of control horny out of
nowhere that you're like I gotta [ __ ]
bang one out like out of control as in
like you there's no control but you guys
have no control no we have no control
I'm just asking if such strong
conviction and urge to do so conviction
is good you know what I mean it takes
you to that level yeah do you guys never
get that like nonchalant yeah and when I
think like even like that frustration of
like [ __ ] I just I'm really in this like
hot mode I would say in junior high or
high school is much more stronger the
older you for guys yeah yeah I think so
because for junior high I was just like
oh my God I gotta [ __ ] jack off and
then you [ __ ] run into a bathroom and
beat it off dude it's like that but
there's girls like that I know I talked
to some and they're like there's women
who are dead girls gotta get their nuts
off too man but not every girl's like
that no no I'm just like I don't think
every guy is like that either I don't
think so every guys yeah I did yeah yeah
I'm sorry I'm sorry what
every [ __ ] guy is like just wait
hurry up and jack off back
hurry up dude
I'm not here dude but like but like my
culture I am very I'm very Ninjutsu
about it you know what I mean what does
that mean I'm very sh you don't even
know I was there there's been you're
ninja jack off
like I've been going to Walmart and then
uh Walmart yeah I'm just at Walmart and
a guy is beating off listening to porn
and jacking off and then I was peeing
and then this Cowboy next to me was like
hey
there's children in here I'll [ __ ] you
up and I was like oh [ __ ] I probably
turned him on even more oh yeah yeah and
then the porn got louder and [ __ ] and
then I was like oh he just turns Up the
Volume oh really dude and then I think
he was like after he died got done
pissing he was like banging on the door
I better stop that [ __ ] and I was like
oh [ __ ] this guy's about to tear the
door down dude he was like this big ass
like old school Cowboy you know in
Arizona yeah dude come on son [ __ ]
what's going on there stop [ __ ]
Walmart
and I was like what the [ __ ] this guy's
about to get his ass kicked dude oh his
first mistake was going to Walmart he
don't got headphones bro come on I
[ __ ] got out of there dude speaking
of your cool shirt I've done the Beats
sorry when I connected to the speaker
and then pick it up no the family
vacations and [ __ ] and you're just like
all right and I'm like you know what
definitely [ __ ]
I'll be back and I leave I forgot like
my phone's connected to the speaker and
then I'm like I can't hear it God damn
and I'm turning it up and I'm just
scaring like oh yeah let's see that big
[ __ ] Cog and I'm like what the [ __ ]
it's over there and everybody's like
what the [ __ ] and I'm like
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's why you pointed at me Japanese
would Japan and jack off why would I not
point at you and who the [ __ ] I know we
we I'm saying we because like my ancient
DNA is tied to that horniness it's so
bad so uh there's a bit of kind of like
this debate because of uh the way that
people use convenience store restrooms
there's definitely been Ninja Japanese
that just kind of go in and use it and
think is uh in their culture and
inconvenience stores in Japan you can
use their restrooms right you just kind
of go in yes it's convenient exactly
blowing out at the complete
I don't know I don't know if that was as
far as it would have normally go for
everybody but feel free to educate me
but you know what if you've ever been to
a bathroom in Japan though it does have
this feeling of I'll beat one off you
know why because it's so clean it's very
it's very comfortable put your feet up
it's not like a it's not like a bathroom
here where it looks like somebody
probably got murdered like one of the if
you go on a road trip right you go in a
gas station you're like man who who
shit's in here like it's scary right
like if you go so if Japanese
restaurants are they're clean public you
go to the park you can lean on the walls
dude it's got the days dude it's got the
days
if you feel self-conscious about going
to the bathroom by yourself they already
like play peeing noise yeah like that's
like an ambient noise get the [ __ ] out
of here that's so next level yeah just
so that you're not like you don't feel
like you're the only one there I feel
like the only place I would want to
Buster that would be in the [ __ ]
restrooms now like she's like it's very
inviting you know I only want to do it
in my room no I gotta go to a
convenience store but the uh the man
that happened is that some people some
people go there and they just kind of
use it and then some people feel very
compelled to have to be like can I use a
restroom like regardless even though
it's like allowed to you still want to
show proper manners and be like I you
know may I use a Russian there's this uh
sociology teacher though who is
conflicted because he both has this very
strong urge that he needs to bust a nut
and he also has this very strong
necessity to express his manners so he
goes to uh a convenience store and he's
like can I please use a restroom to
masturbate why would you say that yeah
you're just being polite but even dudes
that masturbate don't say that can I go
they don't even say even people need to
take a [ __ ] don't say can I use your
bathroom to take a [ __ ] they just go can
I use the restroom he's don't say
gentlemen no no I said honest person I'm
just trying to be transparent hey you
know what dude I would love if I was a
store owner I would love if somebody
asked me dude really get the [ __ ] out of
here yes
yeah thank you for being honest with me
but no yeah you would stop what you're
doing sure I want to thank you for being
honest but get your sick [ __ ] ass out
of here oh it's bad but you know the
restroom across the street is super down
for them yeah they love it but what
about but if you buy a hundred dollars
worth of merchandise you could jerk off
I would stutter I would start at [ __ ]
Japanese [ __ ] restroom jack off Zone
where there are a bunch of like whatever
you already explained a business that
they already have that's why I'm so
surprised that what yeah yeah there is
there's places where you can walk in and
they got jack off stalls with [ __ ]
everything hey everything's ready to go
hey bud uh what's going on with your
people on master
hey buddy uh what the [ __ ] is up with
these people
[ __ ] I wonder if there's correlation
to the uh decline in pregnancies and
having children how much they masturbate
oh why are you why why are you guys
making it weird they also have love
hotels
no they're making it weird by making it
like
because because it's open hey hey man go
home and check off in your room like a
normal person tell them about the love
hotels there's love hotels
he's making it weird I'm making it weird
I'm making it weird no you're not making
it worse don't make it weird go jack off
right here okay I'm gonna go squeeze one
out dude go check out that bidet dude
that's what happens when you don't have
a prude Christian Nation for a country
yes yes well uh they have love hotels
that you can rent with your lover and
you can
um like let's say you have a girlfriend
I love hotels or love motels it's themed
it's got cute little like themes it's
not a prostitution ring no no no no
that's the red light district that's
different oh oh here's excuse me for
assuming some gross [ __ ] thing
there's a whole other City the front
desk I'll tell you why I'll tell you why
wait she looks like a [ __ ] get out of
here so for [ __ ] that love each other
they make love in these Realms so it's
not like here where it's easy to move
out most people live with their family
and then the walls are thin so that's
why you don't have much privacy oh my
God yeah that makes sense so then let's
find a man they they yeah they knew that
there was a yeah because if you're
dating in college and you're like in
your 20s like you want to do adult [ __ ]
but you can't bring a girl home because
you got Grandma and uncle and everybody
yeah there's also similar to Korea has
its [ __ ] crazy if you want to beat
off you're gonna get walked into yes
this makes sense that's why it's so
normal it's like even in Korea they have
like a very very strong drinking culture
which is why the love Motel makes sense
everybody gets like super [ __ ] up it's
very casual to do that right and it's
also very casual to just rent a really
cheap motel for the night that's themed
specifically for that stuff so it
literally just every night there's this
ecosystem I mean well I wasn't but dude
when I was 17 I I couldn't afford no my
love Hotel was my car
that was a love Hotel well no one has
cars out there that's the problem let's
get some cars in that [ __ ] make sure
you don't [ __ ] answer some money in
love in the hotel you know find a little
[ __ ] dark street corner like every
normal person yeah go to make out points
I like the receptionist pushing away
[ __ ] because this is only for love
making yeah for the couples only they
just come in and [ __ ] it's like a net
High [ __ ] hey get the hell out of
here you [ __ ]
I'm just like you [ __ ] only for
people that love each other in this
[ __ ] this is called a love Hotel love
are you in love it says do they [ __ ]
walk by the hallways you can tell by the
moans like oh that's not love noises
love noises
that's what we're looking for we're not
looking for ah we're looking we want
love making here that's love making
noise sex not the ah there should be a
love Hotel manager it's a lot noise
excuse me it doesn't sound like you're
making any love they got the clipboards
yeah I got people waiting like they're
out of here I know right don't ever come
back here again with that [ __ ] [ __ ] ah
this whole [ __ ] segment got me rock
hard I appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign